Shure: 6个吧
Shure: Six, I think.
Shure: 算老板6个
Shure: Including the boss, six.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 什么东西别瞎说
Shure: What? Don't talk nonsense.
Shure: 没事反正每天结300挺好的
Shure: It's fine, earning 300 a day is pretty good anyway.
Shure: 我在里面挺好的妈哈哈哈
Shure: I'm doing pretty well in there, hahaha.
Shure: 安全安全
Shure: Safe, safe.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 那呗
Shure: Okay then.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 嗯那主要攒着买买买
Shure: Hmm, mainly saving up to buy, buy, buy.
Shure: 买买票呢
Shure: To buy tickets.
Shure: 啊把票买完了
Shure: Ah, bought all the tickets.
Shure: 26号的中午
Shure: On the 26th, at noon.
Shure: 提前一天
Shure: One day in advance.
Shure: 学校有点排练
Shure: The school has some rehearsals.
Shure: 嗯就算了
Shure: Hmm, never mind.
Shure: 不提前也不赶
Shure: If we don't do it in advance, we won't dare anyway.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 酒店还没
Shure: The hotel isn't booked yet.
Shure: 酒店还在挑选挑选
Shure: We're still selecting a hotel.
Shure: 你就在携程上看
Shure: Just check on Ctrip.
Shure: 然后携程上看完之后
Shure: And after checking on Ctrip,
Shure: 去那个找他们那个官方APP
Shure: go to their official app and see if it's cheaper.
Shure: 看看能不能便宜点
Shure: If it's not cheaper,
Shure: 如果那便宜不了
Shure: then just book it there directly.
Shure: 然后就就直接在那点订就差不多
Shure: That should be fine.
Shure: 上海吗
Shure: In Shanghai?
Shure: 400吧 400以里
Shure: 400, within 400.
Shure: 就是不
Shure: Just don't—
Shure: 只要你不住那个南京路那片的话
Shure: as long as you don't stay in the Nanjing Road area.
Shure: 嗯嗯
Shure: Hmm, hmm.
Shure: 嗯那我不能拿回来
Shure: Hmm, I can't bring it back.
Shure: 其实也行
Shure: Actually, I can.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Shure: 正好拎啊
Shure: Just carry it.
Shure: 正好拎个大的吧
Shure: Just bring a big one.
Shure: 就你说每次出去玩咋整啊
Shure: Like, every time you go out, what do you do?
Shure: 用用他的箱子呗
Shure: Just use his suitcase.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 嗯行
Shure: Hmm, okay.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 我看着看情况吧
Shure: I'll see how it goes.
Shure: 东西不多我就我就拿着
Shure: If there's not much stuff, I'll just carry it.
Shure: 东西多我就发回来
Shure: If there's a lot, I'll ship it back.
Shure: 嗯是的
Shure: Hmm, yes.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 这怎么还整整个新房呢
Shure: Why are you still working on the new house?
Shure: 嗯行好
Shure: Hmm, okay.
Shure: 嗯好
Shure: Hmm, sure.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Shure: 嗯嗯哈
Shure: Mm-hmm, yeah
Shure: 嗯好
Shure: Mm, okay
Shure: 好嗯好
Shure: Alright, mm, okay
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm
Shure: 嗯没定
Shure: Mm, undecided
Shure: 你看我都能买到吧
Shure: Look, I could still buy it, right?
Shure: 嗯不行让刘海坐个飞机回来不也行
Shure: Mm, if it doesn't work, let Liu Hai fly back, it’s fine too
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 行再说嗯呐嗯呐再商量再商量
Shure: Alright, let's talk about it later, yeah, yeah, we’ll discuss it again
Shure: 不回
Shure: Not coming back
Shure: 嗯他们毕设都晚姚少
Shure: Mm, their graduation project is delayed, Yao Shao
Shure: 但是不是姚少
Shure: But not Yao Shao
Shure: 是姚少正好实习完事他
Shure: It’s Yao Shao, just finished his internship
Shure: 但是他也没回来不回来
Shure: But he didn’t come back, not coming back
Shure: 嗯就是他们
Shure: Mm, it’s them
Shure: 他们那个学校要求有那个实习
Shure: Their school requires that internship
Shure: 就是海关那会吧
Shure: It was at the customs, right?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm
Shure: 然后实习一个月就
Shure: Then one month of internship
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm
Shure: 然后等着8月份入职
Shure: Then waiting to start in August
Shure: 也一直没没问反正他在忙毕设
Shure: Haven’t asked much, anyway, he’s busy with the graduation project
Shure: 等等等到时候见面再说吧
Shure: Let's wait and discuss when we meet
Shure: 这阵好吗
Shure: How about this time?
Shure: 怎么炫耀一下子其实吗
Shure: How to show off actually, right?
Shure: 行反正再到时候看再说吧
Shure: Alright, we’ll see and talk about it then
Shure: 啊啊对特别起眼吧
Shure: Yeah, yeah, it’s really noticeable, right?
Shure: 嗯嗯
Shure: Mm-hmm
Shure: 是不知道
Shure: Don't know
Shure: 是就姚少混最好
Shure: It’s just that Yao Shao is doing the best
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Yeah, yeah
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 小卡拉皮索
Shure: Little Kalapiso
Shure: 啊嗯
Shure: Ah hmm
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 他考哪他们都没保吗
Shure: Did he take the exam? Didn't they all recommend him?
Shure: 那
Shure: Then
Shure: 会混的还不如王攀呢
Shure: He can't even compete with Wang Pan
Shure: 考哪了
Shure: Where did he take the exam?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay
Shure: 挺好啊都
Shure: Pretty good, everyone
Shure: 啊啊好像有点印象
Shure: Ah, I seem to remember a little
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 好像是吧
Shure: Seems like it
Shure: 哎呀不好整不好考啊
Shure: Oh man, it's not easy, not easy at all
Shure: 哎呀没那么好考啊
Shure: Oh man, it's not that easy
Shure: 他们首先你像那个那谁和那谁
Shure: First of all, like that guy and the other guy
Shure: 他他们都不考数学
Shure: They don't take math
Shure: 他们就是专业课和英语还有那什么吗
Shure: They only take professional courses and English, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Shure: 对对
Shure: Yeah, right
Shure: 对难易程度也不一样
Shure: Yeah, the difficulty levels are different too
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 哎呀不好铺了呀
Shure: Oh man, it's hard to manage
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 我这
Shure: I'm here
Shure: 嗯都在学校吧
Shure: Hmm, everyone is probably at school
Shure: 我不知道我都一周没回去了
Shure: I don't know, I haven't been back for a week
Shure: 他们可能都想我了吧
Shure: They might all be missing me
Shure: 他们知道我来来这
Shure: They know I came here
Shure: 嗯当时还还还叫他们他们不来
Shure: Hmm, at the time, I even invited them but they didn't come
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 学习玩
Shure: Studying and playing
Shure: 玩你看这是
Shure: Playing, you see
Shure: 逛逛公园啥的
Shure: Walking around the park and stuff
Shure: 一整就看群里卡群收款
Shure: All of a sudden, we see in the group chat, card payments
Shure: 今天去拿拿拿车费
Shure: Today, we're going to collect the travel expenses
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 可不是
Shure: Exactly
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 他还好像还没有找着什么
Shure: He seems like he hasn't found anything yet.
Shure: 没没信呢
Shure: No news yet.
Shure: 我不知道我不知道
Shure: I don't know, I don't know.
Shure: 他要没有应届生身份那就更难了
Shure: If he doesn't have a fresh graduate status, it'll be even harder.
Shure: 说你你你这你这好像
Shure: You, you, you seem like...
Shure: 你说上那那那得能去啊对吧
Shure: You said there, there, you need to be able to go, right?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 是北邮是个好学校
Shure: Beiyou is a good school.
Shure: 嗯呐我收拾屋子了
Shure: Yeah, I cleaned the room.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 你收拾一下屋子
Shure: You clean up the room.
Shure: 收拾收拾
Shure: Clean it up.
Shure: 今天300就又混到手了呗
Shure: Got another 300 today.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 干了七天半吧算是
Shure: Worked for seven and a half days, I think.
Shure: 差不多
Shure: About right.
Shure: 差不多我买的去的去的去的
Shure: Roughly, I bought, bought, bought...
Shure: 高铁就六六百多块钱
Shure: The high-speed rail ticket was over 600 yuan.
Shure: 北京到那个上海
Shure: From Beijing to Shanghai.
Shure: 哎呦对呀
Shure: Oh right.
Shure: 高铁都6百多
Shure: High-speed rail costs over 600.
Shure: 为啥不看看飞机呢
Shure: Why not check out flights?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 呵我天呐
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 坐4个多小时
Shure: It takes over 4 hours.
Shure: 他那个特别特别快
Shure: It's really, really fast.
Shure: 嗯就时间跟到咱家是差不多的
Shure: Hmm, the time is almost the same as getting to our home.
Shure: 就是飞机好像有的好像能比这便宜
Shure: Actually, some flights might be cheaper.
Shure: 好像还
Shure: Maybe...
Shure: 我忘了我就寻思高铁肯定最便宜的
Shure: I forgot, I thought high-speed rail would be the cheapest.
Shure: 然后后来想起来不对
Shure: Then I realized it wasn't.
Shure: 好像这架飞机也下来了
Shure: Looks like the flight came down in price too.
Shure: 他花呀怎么
Shure: How much did he spend?
Shure: 就正常的就是我
Shure: Just the usual, it's me.
Shure: 我定点这个他定点那个的
Shure: I handle this while he handles that.
Shure: 我们俩就也不分那么细
Shure: We don't really divide things that precisely.
Shure: 你比如我我我我出去玩啥的
Shure: For example, when I go out to play or something,
Shure: 我我我订那个车票什么的
Shure: I book the tickets and stuff,
Shure: 然后他就订酒店之类的
Shure: and he books the hotel and stuff.
Shure: 我这两天不是那什么吗
Shure: Haven't I been away the past few days?
Shure: 不在吗我
Shure: I haven't been around, right?
Shure: 明天回当我上班了
Shure: I'll be back at work tomorrow.
Shure: 行行我25号肯定给你整
Shure: Okay, I'll definitely get it done by the 25th.
Shure: 行吧就25号那天你回来就得带着呗
Shure: Alright, on the 25th, you just have to bring it along.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 手链啊手链
Shure: The bracelet, the bracelet.
Shure: 我放放那什么了
Shure: I left it, you know, somewhere.
Shure: 放那个学校桌子上了
Shure: I left it on the school desk.
Shure: 没带他有的时候弹吉他啥的不方便
Shure: Didn't bring it because sometimes it's inconvenient when playing guitar.
Shure: 还要打鼓啥的
Shure: And when drumming too.
Shure: 有的时候怕那鼓槌一下伸里面去
Shure: Sometimes I'm afraid the drumstick might get stuck in it.
Shure: 然后给他给他再别折
Shure: And it might get bent or something.
Shure: 对呀他不是有稍微有点空间吗
Shure: Yeah, it has a bit of space, right?
Shure: 然后窜吧窜吧有的时候就一下窜进来
Shure: Sometimes it slips in just like that.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 都都是
Shure: All of them.
Shure: 白金现在不值钱了
Shure: Platinum isn't worth much now.
Shure: 嗯嗯
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mhm.
Shure: 嗯呐看到了
Shure: Uh-huh, I see it.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 你你分析分析吧
Shure: You analyze it.
Shure: 不知道我哪知道
Shure: I don't know, how would I know?
Shure: 我又没学过经济学
Shure: I never studied economics.
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahahaha, okay, okay.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 长远
Shure: Long-term.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 啥玩意
Shure: What the heck?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Shure: 挺好
Shure: Pretty good.
Shure: 不用了不用了
Shure: No need, no need.
Shure: 嗯嗯我待会回去再说
Shure: Mm-hmm, I'll talk about it when I get back.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm.
Shure: 是嗯
Shure: Yes, mm.
Shure: 对反正我到处整就行
Shure: Yeah, as long as I handle it everywhere, it's fine.
Shure: 那是
Shure: That's right.
Shure: 你告告诉他钱到位啥都能给他整出来
Shure: Just tell him, as long as the money is there, everything can be sorted out.
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 全屋定制
Shure: Custom-made for the whole house.
Shure: 啥人那个智能家居
Shure: What kind of smart home.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm.
Shure: 好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 好
Shure: Good.
Shure: 真好
Shure: Really good.
Shure: 好好写完再说
Shure: Alright, finish writing it and we'll talk later.
Shure: 嗯好嗯拜拜
Shure: Mm-hmm, okay, bye-bye.
Shure: 乐死
Shure: So funny.
其他人：别坐
Other: Don't sit.
Shure: 了
Shure: Okay.
其他人：它上面有小猫爪印
Other: There are cat paw prints on it.
Shure: 哦真的哎
Shure: Oh, really?
其他人：然后昨天晚上没有吃完的饭
Other: And the food we didn't finish last night.
其他人： 不知道被哪个小野猫吃掉了哦
Other: I don't know which stray cat ate it.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 来偷腥了小猫
Shure: The cat came to sneak some food.
Shure: 妈问候问候你
Shure: Mom says hello to you.
其他人：啊问候我干嘛
Other: Huh, why is she saying hello to me?
其他人：你怎么就是有的人打电话都闲不住啊
Other: How come some people can't sit still even when they're on the phone?
其他人：就那种人
Other: Just those people.
Shure: 是的你知道我们办公室吧
Shure: Yeah, you know in our office.
Shure: 就是有一个哥跟我一样
Shure: There's a guy just like me.
Shure: 他只要一打电话就全屋就开始这么走
Shure: As soon as he gets on the phone, he starts walking all over the place.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure: 贼有趣
Shure: It's so funny.
其他人：问候我干嘛要问候我
Other: Why is she saying hello to me?
Shure: 问候问候问候
Shure: Saying hello, saying hello.
Shure: 我们有没有长远打算
Shure: Do we have any long-term plans?
Shure: 艾文你这怎么了
Shure: Evan, what's up with you?
Shure: 这红了这坏了这
Shure: This is red, this is broken.
其他人：哪啊
Others: Where?
Shure: 天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
其他人：怎么了
Others: What's wrong?
Shure: 红了
Shure: It's red.
Shure: 头皮
Shure: The scalp.
Shure: 挠的
Shure: From scratching.
Shure: 别挠了
Shure: Stop scratching.
Shure: 杨老板你好
Shure: Hello, Jake.
Jake:你好
Jake: Hello.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh dear.
Jake:另一个老板了
Jake: Another boss.
Shure: 啊不是刚才是家里的大老板
Shure: Ah, no, that was the big boss at home.
Shure: 我妈
Shure: My mom.
Shure: 呵呵问候一下我这几天都在干嘛
Shure: Haha, she was asking what I've been up to these days.
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Haha.
Jake:那你怎么汇报
Jake: So what did you report?
Jake: 这几天吃吃喝喝
Jake: Just eating and drinking these days?
Shure: 我说吃吃喝喝
Shure: I said eating and drinking.
Shure: 然后再说哎呀妈
Shure: Then said, oh my mom.
Shure: 哈哈哈我说不是
Shure: Haha, I said it's not.
Shure: 你看我刚才就给AI诠释了一下
Shure: See, I just explained to AI what our job is.
Shure: 我们这个工作
Shure: Our work.
Jake: 可以一个总结性术语
Jake: You can use a summarizing term.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:是是他
Jake: It is, is it?
Shure: 他不是吧
Shure: It's not, right?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Jake:那你妈妈觉得怎么样算是呢
Jake: So what does your mom think qualifies as one?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 粘的一圈柳絮毛毛
Shure: There's a bunch of willow catkins stuck.
Shure: 我们要叫他们起床吗
Shure: Should we wake them up?
Shure: 还是等菜到的
Shure: Or wait until the food arrives?
Shure: 今天点的什么
Shure: What did we order today?
Jake:点了
Jake: Ordered.
Jake:  5盘盘那种东北菜吧啊
Jake: Five dishes of that kind of northeastern cuisine, right?
Jake:家常菜
Jake: Home-cooked dishes.
其他人：你pad还有电吗
Other: Does your iPad still have battery?
Shure: 有怎么了
Shure: Yes, why?
其他人：你拿一下吧
Other: Can you take it?
Shure: 要看一会剧
Shure: Want to watch a show for a while.
Shure: 给我放干净地啊
Shure: Make sure to put it in a clean place.
Shure: 哎呀收拾收拾
Shure: Oh, tidy up a bit.
Shure: 呦早上好
Shure: Oh, good morning.
Lucia: 早上好
Lucia: Good morning.
Shure: 你的室友们都醒醒了吗
Shure: Are your roommates all awake?
Lucia: 醒了吧
Lucia: They should be awake.
Lucia: 我刚才前面出门的时候还看到了
Lucia: I saw them when I went out earlier.
Shure: 雨轩醒了吗
Shure: Is Yuxuan awake?
Lucia: 雨轩不确定
Lucia: Not sure about Yuxuan.
Shure: 雨轩他铁没醒
Shure: Yuxuan is definitely not awake.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure: 他要是醒了我把休字倒过来写
Shure: If he is awake, I will write "Shu" backwards.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 来公主
Shure: Come here, princess.
其他人：什么
Other: What?
其他人：啊怎么了
Other: Ah, what's up?
其他人：哎还可以
Other: Hey, it's okay.
Shure: 雷桥
Shure: Leiqiao.
其他人：还可以哦
Other: It's okay.
其他人：银河快递也好
Other: Galaxy Express is good too.
Shure: 我靠来一个来一个来一个
Shure: Damn, bring one, bring one, bring one.
Jake:搁冰箱里呢
Jake: It's in the fridge.
Jake:不然你还得再吃
Jake: Otherwise, you have to eat again.
Jake:还得再吃一个
Jake: Have to eat another one.
Lucia: 昨天晚上刷个电影
Lucia: Watched a movie last night.
Jake:刷什么
Jake: Watched what?
Lucia: 刷个电影
Lucia: Watched a movie.
Shure: 叫刷个电影
Shure: You call it "watching a movie"?
Shure: 电影都按刷来那什么的吗
Shure: Do you watch movies like you binge-watch shows?
Lucia: 不是就是
Lucia: No, it's just...
Lucia: 我在想怎么形容
Lucia: I was thinking how to describe it.
Lucia: 看电影跟刷剧这个行动联系在一起
Lucia: Watching movies and binge-watching shows are similar actions.
Lucia: 哦所以我一般不刷剧
Lucia: Oh, so I usually don't binge-watch.
Lucia: Shure:
Lucia: 但是解释我看
Lucia: But explaining, I watched...
Lucia: 了个电影
Lucia: ...a movie.
Shure: 给你
Shure: Here you go.
Shure: 美女
Shure: Beautiful.
Shure: 要吃咸鸭蛋吗
Shure: Want a salted duck egg?
其他人：要啊
Others: Yes!
Shure: 没品
Shure: No taste.
Shure: 我觉得他俩一起吃肯定好吃
Shure: I think the two of them eating together will be delicious.
Shure: 你帮我打开呗
Shure: Can you open this for me?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
其他人：干嘛你拉干嘛
Others: What are you pulling?
Shure: 贺有牙真厉害
Shure: He has strong teeth.
其他人：你没有吗
Others: Don't you?
Shure: 我不会用
Shure: I don't know how to use them.
其他人：吃不了太多了
Others: Can't eat too much.
其他人：你把你那个吃一半给我好
Others: Give me half of what you're eating.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
其他人：太甜了这个奶油看着就很甜
Others: This cream looks so sweet.
Shure: 嗯很好
Shure: Yeah, it's good.
Shure: 太甜了
Shure: Too sweet.
其他人：嗯有点腻
Others: Yeah, it's a bit greasy.
Shure: 帮我打开一下帮我打开
Shure: Help me open it, please.
Lucia: 你拿啥
Lucia: What are you holding?
Shure: 他不吃我要把他放下
Shure: He doesn't eat it, so I'm putting it down.
Shure: 啊这嘎的一二
Shure: Ah, here, one, two...
Lucia: 等我三秒钟
Lucia: Wait for three seconds.
Lucia: 这么较真啊
Lucia: So serious?
Shure: 咱说3秒就3秒
Shure: We said three seconds, so it's three seconds.
Lucia: 那可不
Lucia: Of course.
Shure: 嗯好香
Shure: Mmm, smells good.
其他人：哎呀怎么可以单曲啊
Others: How can you play it on a loop?
其他人：听点周一该听的歌
Others: Listen to songs suitable for Monday.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：没听过吗
Others: Haven't you heard it?
Shure: 我没听过
Shure: I haven't.
Shure: 我可以用你的头敲两蛋吗
Shure: Can I crack two eggs with your head?
其他人：不可以很疼的
Others: No, it hurts a lot.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
其他人：嗯
Others: Yeah.
其他人：（歌词）我真的想逃离
Others: (Lyrics) I really want to escape.
其他人：（歌词）逃离这星期天
Others: (Lyrics) Escape this Sunday.
其他人：（歌词）同时欺骗我自
Others: (Lyrics) Deceiving myself at the same time.
其他人：（歌词）我不想再失去你
Others: (Lyrics) I don't want to lose you again
其他人：然后你转来转去
Others: And then you keep spinning around
其他人：转人很容易
Others: Spinning people is easy
其他人：你快坐下吧
Others: Just sit down already
其他人：哎呀正好坐那小猫爪子上
Others: Oh no, you sat right on the little cat's paw
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's okay
其他人：两天好多朋友去上迪上迪
Others: Many friends went to Didi these two days
Shure: 上迪
Shure: To Didi
Shure: i为什么发的那么奇怪
Shure: Why does he pronounce "I" so weirdly?
Shure: 我说这个歌手的i发的特别奇怪
Shure: I'm saying this singer's "I" sounds really strange
其他人： 每周杀死一遍星期一
Others: Kill Monday every week
Shure: young Taylor
Shure: Young Taylor
Shure: 年轻的裁缝
Shure: Young tailor
其他人：搞说唱的不都这样吗
Others: Aren't all rappers like this?
其他人：起些奇奇怪怪的名字
Others: They come up with weird names
Shure: 嘿嘿咸鸭蛋
Shure: Hehe salted duck egg
其他人：卧槽他俩怎么会
Others: Damn, how did they...
其他人：敢次元必破了哎
Others: The dimensions must be breaking
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Shure: 那我求哥是不是要开巡演了
Shure: Is the tour starting soon?
其他人：我怎么感觉他一直在巡演
Others: I feel like he's been touring forever
Shure: 没有吧
Shure: No way
其他人：去年不是有那个水族馆的巡演吗
Others: Didn't he have that aquarium tour last year?
其他人：（歌词）我学不会更改
Others: (Lyrics) I can't learn to change
其他人：（歌词）只因为你有你给我的精彩
Others: (Lyrics) Just because you bring me so much excitement
Alice:你那是什么第五
Alice: What is that, the fifth...
其他人：第五人格
Others: Identity V
Jake:还有一公里
Jake: One more kilometer
Tasha: 这这啥
Tasha: What is this?
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah, ah
Jake:你没开
Tasha: 这还没开
Tasha: It's not open yet
Jake:它如果让你到多少次那就该输了
Jake: If it lets you so many times, then you should lose
Shure: 你看你这电话
Shure: Look at your phone
Tasha: 好了好了好了
Tasha: Okay, okay, okay
Shure: 干嘛
Shure: What?
其他人：is that long girl
Others: Is that long girl?
其他人：他真的拉上了
Others: He really pulled it off
Shure: 嗯好多了
Shure: Hmm, much better
Shure: 给大家看一些帮人类拉拉下来的
Shure: Showing everyone some stuff we got for humanity
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 咸鸭蛋一点都不好吃
Shure: Salted duck eggs are not tasty at all.
Shure: 我说这咸鸭蛋一点都不好吃
Shure: I'm telling you, these salted duck eggs are not tasty at all.
Shure: 怎么到了
Shure: How did we get here?
Jake:到了
Jake: We're here.
Shure: 太好了饭到了
Shure: Great, the food is here.
Shure: 又啃着手指头
Shure: Still biting your fingers?
Shure: 咋了
Shure: What's wrong?
Shure: 倒呛刺
Shure: Choking a bit?
Shure: 别啃
Shure: Don't bite.
其他人：哎呀不用上班真好
Others: Ah, it's so nice not having to work.
Shure: 早上往这一坐
Shure: Just sitting here in the morning.
Shure: 这7天都是这样的日子
Shure: These seven days are going to be like this.
Shure: 爽翻跟你讲
Shure: So great, I'm telling you.
Shure: 不爽
Shure: Not great.
Shure: 不爽啊看你享福
Shure: Not great, seeing you enjoy it.
其他人：我不爽
Others: I'm not happy.
Shure: 是不叫你来着嗯
Shure: Didn't we call you to come?
Shure: 其实每天根本就不用什么搜索
Shure: Actually, there's no need to search for anything every day.
其他人：看那个手机屏幕倒影好圆哦
Others: Look, the phone screen reflection is so round.
Shure: 这个吗啊
Shure: This one? Ah.
其他人：我是刚才亮度能把自己的脸映出来
Others: Just now, the brightness could reflect my face.
其他人：就可能头发扎起来其实不觉得圆
Others: Maybe if I tie my hair up, it doesn't feel round.
其他人：然后一旦散下来就觉得圆圆的
Others: But once it's down, it feels round.
Jake:家人们吃饭
Jake: Time to eat, everyone.
其他人：准备好了吗
Others: Are you ready?
Shure: 我把那谁叫下来
Shure: I'll call that person down.
Jake:对你把勾叫下来
Jake: Yeah, call Gou down.
Jake:然后把眼睛给她放上来
Jake: And bring her eyes up.
Shure: 起床啦
Shure: Wake up!
Shure: 雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan
Shure: 雨轩起床了
Shure: Yuxuan, wake up.
Shure: 雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan
Shure: 哦你在厕所是吗
Shure: Oh, are you in the bathroom?
Shure: 起床了下楼吃饭了
Shure: Get up, come downstairs to eat.
Shure: 咋了不舒服喝多了
Shure: What's wrong? Not feeling well? Drank too much?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah?
Shure: 喝多了
Shure: Drank too much?
Katrina: 天哪头有点晕晕的
Katrina: Oh man, my head feels a bit dizzy.
Shure: 开始呕了吗
Shure: Are you starting to throw up?
Shure: 天
Shure: Oh dear.
Shure: 晚上干嘛呢昨天
Shure: What did you do last night?
Katrina: 不知道
Katrina: I don't know.
Katrina:  不知道啊我靠昨天晚上说我什么了
Katrina: I don't know, oh my, what did I say last night?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈你还是还发发的语音是吗
Shure: Hahaha, did you send those voice messages?
Shure: 然后现在自己不敢点开看了是吧
Shure: And now you don't dare to open them, right?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈别笑
Shure: Hahahahahaha, don't laugh.
Katrina: 别笑我
Katrina: Don't laugh at me.
Shure: 没有我也有那么一长串的语音
Shure: No, I also have a long string of voice messages.
Shure: 至今为止都没有点开过
Shure: I've never opened them to this day.
Katrina: 真的是太
Katrina: It's really too...
Katrina: 你们吃早饭了吗
Katrina: Have you guys had breakfast?
Shure: 这不叫你来吃早饭的吗
Shure: Didn't we ask you to come for breakfast?
Shure: 差不多
Shure: Almost.
Katrina: 还戴眼镜是吧
Katrina: You're still wearing glasses, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 就放这了
Shure: Just leave it here.
Shure: 哎上来把电脑取了
Shure: Hey, come up and get the computer.
Shure: 丽特找我干活了
Shure: Litte asked me to do some work.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 我领导找我干活了
Shure: My boss asked me to do some work.
Shure: 哈喽成功了
Shure: Hello, it worked.
Jake:成功了吗
Jake: Did it work?
Shure: 他醒了居然已经
Shure: He actually woke up already.
Shure: 我还敲他门呢
Shure: I was still knocking on his door.
Shure: 然后结果他在厕所呢
Shure: And it turns out he was in the bathroom.
Jake:哦白敲门了
Jake: Oh, you knocked for nothing.
Shure: 可不是吗
Shure: Exactly.
Jake:发现咱好像是八个人
Jake: Seems like we are eight people.
Tasha: 哼但是我发现米饭可以刚下锅
Tasha: Hmph, but I found out the rice can just be cooked.
Tasha:  如果米饭吃半碗的话
Tasha: If we each have half a bowl of rice...
Jake:好咱少吃点
Jake: Okay, let's eat a little less.
Tasha: 你就这样直接戴
Tasha: Just wear it like this.
Jake:要不然
Jake: Or else...
Tasha: 不需要镜子吗
Tasha: Don't you need a mirror?
Shure: 我也不需要
Shure: I don't need one either.
Katrina: 我今天早上问一样的问题
Katrina: I asked the same question this morning.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:我我上一周还是带一个要10分钟
Jake: Last week it took me 10 minutes to wear this.
Jake:我看现在要多久
Jake: Let's see how long it takes now.
Jake:好吧估计要10分钟
Jake: Okay, I guess it'll take 10 minutes.
Tasha: 我来帮你带
Tasha: I'll help you wear it.
Tasha: 一分钟一个
Tasha: One minute for each.
Jake:哈哈我觉得我要成功了
Jake: Haha, I think I'm going to succeed.
Jake:为啥呀为啥很难成功
Jake: Why is it so hard to succeed?
Tasha: 你的手也不消毒吗
Tasha: Aren't you going to disinfect your hands?
Jake:消毒是干嘛的
Jake: What's the point of disinfecting?
Tasha: 就是拿护理液冲一下
Tasha: Just rinse them with some solution.
Jake:就这种东西
Jake: This kind of stuff?
Shure: 没事哎呀
Shure: It's no big deal, geez.
Shure: 不干不净
Shure: A little dirt never hurt.
Shure: 冲了没病
Shure: Rinse it and no problem.
Tasha: 带到眼睛里了
Tasha: It's in your eye now.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine.
Tasha: 我比你好
Tasha: I'm better than you.
Tasha: 我看你昨天戴了好久
Tasha: I saw you took a long time yesterday.
Shure: 我吗
Shure: Me?
Shure: 开玩笑摘来摘
Shure: Just kidding, let's take it off.
Shure: 摘了咱俩battle一下
Shure: We'll have a battle.
Jake:哈哈竞速
Jake: Haha, a speed competition.
Shure: 我能戴两对呵呵呵
Shure: I can wear two pairs, haha.
Shure: 电脑没电了
Shure: The computer's out of power.
Shure: 我靠赶紧插下电
Shure: Damn, I need to plug it in quickly.
Shure: 哎然后把leader 给我的活干完
Shure: Then I need to finish the work the leader gave me.
其他人：我应该昨天吃完了
Others: I should have finished eating it yesterday.
Alice:我不听坏消息
Alice: I don't want to hear bad news.
Alice:你给我非常好消息
Alice: Give me some really good news.
其他人：呃好消息是
Others: Umm, the good news is...
其他人：这个墙可能要穿新衣了
Others: This wall might get new clothes soon.
Alice:搞什么啊
Alice: What's going on?
Alice: 有没有默契
Alice: Do you have any chemistry?
Alice:你接不住你就完了
Alice: If you can't catch it, you're done.
其他人：接不住不吃了
Others: If you can't catch it, you don't eat.
Alice:
Alice:你说你会接住
Alice: You said you'd catch it.
Alice: 这是我们默契大挑战
Alice: This is our chemistry challenge.
Alice:完美
Alice: Perfect.
Jake:作业能撵上吗
Jake: Can you keep up with the homework?
Jake:你一般联系不上谢斌竹怎么办
Jake: What do you do when you can't reach Xie Binzhu?
Alice:他是不是没醒啊
Alice: Is he not awake yet?
Jake:我觉得没醒
Jake: I think he's still asleep.
Shure: （歌词）的路灯杂杂的这条街
Shure: (Lyrics) The street lights clutter this street.
Shure: 刚才稍微工作了一下
Shure: Just did a bit of work earlier.
Shure: 好的今天工作又完成了
Shure: Alright, today's work is done.
Shure: 150块钱又赚到手了
Shure: Earned another 150 bucks.
Shure: 呵唉
Shure: Heh, sigh.
Shure: 每天像像他妈在搞一样
Tasha: 这钱赚的心安吗
Tasha: Do you feel at ease earning this money?
Shure: 我太心安了
Shure: I feel totally at ease.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Oh, come on.
Shure: 我们在这个桌子上吃吗
Shure: Are we eating at this table?
Tasha: 应该是
Tasha: I think so.
Shure: 早上好
Shure: Good morning.
Shure: 嗯重新登一下就好了
Shure: Hmm, just need to log back in.
Lucia: 密码登上
Lucia: Log in with the password.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
其他人：不好意思
Others: Sorry.
其他人：我把我名字漏出来了
Tasha: 我还在想呢
Tasha: I was wondering.
Tasha: 这人是谁
Tasha: Who is that person?
Shure: 不是我还有
Shure: No worries, I still have a ladder.
Shure: 要不我给你们用
Shure: How about you guys use mine?
Shure: 我有
Shure: 用我的
Shure: Use mine.
Jake: 给他个二维码去了
Jake: Give him a QR code.
Jake:给他个账号
Jake: Give him an account.
Shure: 谢斌竹的过期了
Shure: Xie Binzhu's expired.
Shure: 七天
Shure: Seven days.
Jake:七天过去了啊
Jake: Seven days have passed, huh?
Shure: 不是过期了
Shure: No, it's expired.
Shure: 他那个他那个
Shure: It's his, his...
Shure: 应该是就是流量干没了
Shure: I think his data ran out.
Shure: 我感觉可能
Shure: I think maybe.
Shure: 我来吧我来吧
Shure: I'll do it, I'll do it.
Shure: 来
Shure: Here.
Jake:给他们个号我这也有个号
Jake: Give them a number, I have one too.
Shure: 我发了一个
Shure: I sent one already.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 大家复制一下这个然后
Shure: Everyone, copy this and then...
Shure: 那   我给你操作一下子
Shure: I'll handle the little rocket for you.
Shure: 健康的果汁
Shure: Healthy juice.
Shure: 咱还有果汁吗
Shure: Do we still have juice?
Shure: 昨天不都喝完了吗
Shure: Didn't we finish it all yesterday?
Jake:11:52早起床喝一杯健康的果汁
Jake: 11:52 AM, wake up and drink a glass of healthy juice.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 咱健康的果汁只有小麦果汁粮食果汁
Shure: Our healthy juice is just wheat juice, grain juice.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 点开吧我们一起听一下子
Shure: Open it, let's listen together.
Shure: 你一个人不敢点开
Shure: You don't dare to open it alone.
Shure: 我们帮你点开
Shure: We'll help you open it.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:语音
Jake: Voice message.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 这是你的手机吧
Shure: This is your phone, right?
Katrina: 随便随便
Katrina: Whatever, whatever.
Katrina: 好恐怖
Katrina: So scary.
Katrina: 他都不知道怎么回
Katrina: He doesn't even know how to reply.
Shure: 你他回了吗
Shure: Did you reply to him?
Shure: 后来
Shure: Later on.
Shure: 你可以根据他回你的
Shure: You can guess what you said based on his reply.
Shure: 然后你推测一下
Shure: And then speculate.
Shure: 你自己说啥
Shure: What you said.
Shure: 你两位一
Shure: You two,
Shure: 起聊是吗
Shure: chat together, right?
Shure: 真忙啊昨天晚上
Shure: Really busy last night.
Shure: 然后然后还刷我视频干什么
Shure: And then, still watching my videos?
Katrina: 哈哈哈群里讲话
Katrina: Hahaha, talking in the group chat.
Katrina: 然后点开你的朋友圈
Katrina: And then checking your moments.
Shure: 咦
Shure: Eh.
Shure: 我也不知道为什么会被这么叫
Shure: I don't know why I'm called that either.
Shure: 那是谁我都不知道
Shure: Who is that? I don't even know.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: Do you know?
Shure: 怎么了没电了
Shure: What's wrong? Out of battery?
其他人：有点让你帮我拿一下
Others: Can you help me take this?
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure
Jake:走吃饭吃饭
Jake: Let's go eat, let's eat
Shure: 给大家弄点
Shure: Let's get some for everyone
Shure: 东北菜可能哦
Shure: Maybe some Northeastern Chinese dishes
Katrina: 点了外卖了
Katrina: We ordered takeout
Shure: 点了已经
Shure: It's already ordered
Shure: 困
Shure: So tired
Shure: 那你躺下去
Shure: Then lie down
Shure: 吃完饭躺下去
Shure: Lie down after eating
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go
Tasha: 吃饭吗好饿啊
Tasha: Eating? I'm so hungry
Shure: 吃吃这呢
Shure: Yes, let's eat here
Shure: 走rose
Shure: Come on, Rose
其他人：什么什么rose
Others: What, what Rose?
其他人：什么rose什么东西
Others: What Rose, what is that?
Shure: 雨轩老师昨天晚上睡得香吗
Shure: Teacher Yuxuan, did you sleep well last night?
Shure: 雨轩老师
Shure: Teacher Yuxuan
Katrina: 怎么
Katrina: What's up?
Shure: 啊没事坐
Shure: Ah, nothing, sit down
Shure: 东北菜吗
Shure: Northeastern dishes?
Shure: 不知道他说是东北菜
Shure: I don't know, he said it's Northeastern food
Shure: 我看着不像
Shure: It doesn't look like it
其他人：木须肉
Others: Moo Shu Pork
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 土豆丝
Shure: Shredded potatoes
Shure: 柿子炒鸡蛋
Shure: Tomato scrambled eggs
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Katrina: 柿子炒鸡蛋
Katrina: Tomato scrambled eggs
Shure: 呵呵什么
Shure: Haha, what?
其他人：什么
Others: What?
Shure: 嗯他在报菜名
Shure: Hmm, he's listing the dishes
Shure: 应该是吧
Shure: Should be, right?
其他人：啊他这个他怕汤流出来还加了保鲜膜
Others: Ah, he even added plastic wrap to prevent the soup from spilling
Shure: 太贴心了
Shure: So considerate
Shure: 还有每天
Shure: And every day
其他人：我又想起来上次在家吃的那份番茄炒蛋
Others: It reminds me of the tomato scrambled eggs we had at home last time
Shure: 雨轩老师
Shure: Teacher Yuxuan
Shure: 点开看看吧
Shure: Open it and take a look
Shure: 我也很好奇
Shure: I'm curious too
Shure: 没有他的
Shure: He doesn't have it.
Shure: 昨晚发了一些语音
Shure: I sent some voice messages last night.
Shure: 但是自己忘了发啥了
Shure: But I forgot what I sent.
Shure: 然后现在不敢点开哈哈哈
Shure: And now I'm too scared to open them hahaha.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Shure: 请坐
Shure: Please sit.
Shure: 对我给你们
Jake:呃就是在群里修硕发了一个来搞一搞
Jake: Uh, Shure posted in the group to come mess around.
Shure: 好的你走了
Shure: Alright, you're leaving.
Shure: 我抢你的座
Shure: I'll take your seat.
Jake:用修硕的
其他人：你一直在弹消息要看一下吗
Others: You've been getting notifications, want to check them?
Jake:你帮我看一下
Jake: Can you check for me?
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh no.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 你把我手机给我
Shure: Give me my phone.
Jake:允许粘贴加一个
Jake: Allow paste, add one.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
其他人：有啊他突然弹出来了
Others: Yes, it just popped up.
Jake:yes
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 我吓死
Shure: I was scared to death.
Jake:试试喽
Jake: Give it a try.
其他人：密码密码我记不住
Others: Password, password, I can't remember it.
Shure: 我是2了吧唧
Shure: I'm too silly.
Jake:什么东西哈哈哈
Jake: What is that, hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 你告诉AI一些人类机密表的方式
Shure: You tell the AI some human secrets.
Tasha: 你打开了吗啊
Tasha: Did you open it, huh?
Shure: 叫什么把
Shure: What's it called?
Jake:你登一Google看一下啊
Jake: You log into Google and check it out.
Shure: 可能吧
Shure: Maybe.
Shure: 哈哈哈我可以变成
Jake:啊是我吗
Jake: Huh, is it me?
Shure: 我先Trance一下然后再let me一下
Shure: I'll first transform and then let me.
Jake:对是
Jake: Yes, it is.
Shure: 那我跟不Trance的异性有什么区别
Shure: Then what's the difference between me and a non-transgender person of the opposite sex?
其他人：哦不对哦不对哦不对哦
Others: Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Shure: 懂了给你安排一张是吧
Shure: Got it, I'll arrange one for you, right?
其他人：不不不不不nono
其他人：都啥呀
Others: What's all this?
其他人：全部
Others: Everything.
其他人：啊可爱
Others: Aww, so cute.
其他人：嗯是吧全是
Others: Yeah, right? All of it.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Definitely.
Shure: 然后点加号
Shure: Then click the plus sign.
Shure: 进shadow Rocket里面
Shure: Go into Shadow Rocket.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:因为里边太乱了
Jake: Because it's too messy inside.
Jake:其实可以变得比较干净
Jake: Actually, it can be pretty clean.
Jake:但是收拾的时候要戴眼镜所以
Jake: But when tidying up, you need to wear glasses, so...
Jake:延迟了一会
Jake: It got delayed a bit.
Shure: 哪个是我的来着
Shure: Which one is mine again?
Shure: 哦这是他的
Shure: Oh, this is his.
Shure: 给人流量干没了
Shure: Used up all the traffic.
Shure: 今天按按您的要求点了两份炒蛋
Shure: Today I ordered two servings of scrambled eggs as you requested.
Lucia: 啊哈哈笑了
Lucia: Ahaha, laughed.
Shure: 在找什么
Shure: What are you looking for?
其他人：就是看看
Others: Just looking.
其他人：你拍一些什么东西
Others: What are you filming?
Lucia: 我觉得我这个好像
Lucia: I think mine looks like...
其他人：不是你能不能告诉我这是什么呀
Others: Can't you tell me what this is?
Jake:对是呃
Jake: Yeah, it's um...
Jake:你要先打开新民主的那个小
Jake: You need to first open the New Democracy's small rocket.
其他人：什么青蛙哈哈哈
Others: What frog? Hahaha.
Shure: 就是把自己打个码
Shure: Just blur yourself out.
Lucia: 打开他的打开他的
Lucia: Open his, open his small rocket.
Alice:把他的   换成别人的
Alice: Replace his small rocket with someone else's.
Shure: 对就是我给你们
Shure: Yeah, I'll give you guys a small rocket.
Jake:就是这个
Jake: It's this small rocket.
Jake:   之后这边加哎就上来
Jake: After the small rocket, add here, and it's up.
Shure: username和密码是
Shure: The username and password are...
Jake:对呃然后你刚刚复制了吗那个东西
Jake: Yeah, did you just copy that thing?
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Jake:那就把这个给换掉
Jake: Then replace this one.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 嗯到期了吗
Lucia: Is it expired?
Jake:对七天七天过去了
Jake: Yeah, seven days have passed.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No
Shure: 哦你说这个登录到期了是吗
Shure: Oh, you mean the login expired, right?
Jake:呃对是吧
Jake: Uh, yeah, right?
Tasha: 你要开吃了
Tasha: Are you about to start eating?
Jake:对对他少俩人吗
Jake: Yeah, yeah, we are missing two people, right?
Tasha: 对啊少俩人呢
Tasha: Yeah, we're missing two people.
Tasha: 你去喊一下吧去
Tasha: Can you go call them?